Mindi is renowned for her incredible
flexibility in dexterity but is she good
enough to get through the laser beams
and avoid triggering an alarm as she
tries will measure her every move with
the advanced technology of the fight
science lab so Mindy what we're gonna do
is we're gonna put about 16 sensors all
over your body and what its gonna tell
us is exactly kind of the joint angles
of your arms your legs your torso as you
maneuver our obstacle course that we've
set up for you the sensors of this
system accurately measure body position
and movement in three dimensions
hold still we're gonna calibrate the
data is transmitted in real time to a
computer put your arms out that displays
a virtual image of Mindy's skeleton in
motion the computer will record the
range of motion of Mindy's spine and
limbs scientists can then assess why
Mindy succeeds or fails do not break any
of those laser beams as you're coming
out okay and to simulate the pressure of
an actual ninja strike Mindy will have
only 60 seconds to circumvent the lasers
and escape this 20 by 20 foot room okay
you ready
three two one begin
Mindy's martial arts training gives him
more than double the range of motion of
an average human being
I mean she's repositioning her legs but
the only way she's moving is with her
arms and her arms are doing all the work
look at that
hello she is when this superhuman
flexibility is combined with her
extraordinary sense of balance it allows
Mindy to squeeze through spaces too
tight for a normal person and there's
one more skill shared by ninja and great
athletes throughout the centuries
it's called kinesthetic awareness a
precise knowledge of where every part of
her body is located as it travels
through space mind and body working in
perfect harmony and she's getting her to
come out think she's real close to the
edge here Wow jab is awesome I am I am
truly impressed I mean look at all the
different lasers in here and you didn't
hit any of them
I just used the method of movement that
I felt would be the quickest and safest
route for me and I think it worked
Mindy beat the clock without tripping a
single beam but how did she do it a look
inside her body reveals the secrets of
her stealth in her very first move
Mindy bends her spine backwards at 70
degrees extension a normal person can
barely achieve 30 degrees extension when
Mindy goes into the splits her right hip
abduction reaches 117 degrees while her
left hip hits 100 degrees
normal passive hip abduction is 45 to 50
degrees in her final move a backflip
over the laser beam
Mindy spine angle again reaches 70
degrees extension a number usually only
seen in Olympic gymnasts her mind and
body work in perfect harmony planning
and executing her escape